[Music]
ADT's late-night roundup your quick
catch up on all the best TV scoop after
dark it's very pure it's unconditional
on The Late Show with Stephen Colbert
John Legend adorably opened up about
holding his daughter Luna for the first
time it's very emotional
and it brings you and your wife closer
together and it's a very like powerful
feeling to see the product of your love
right there the Oscar winner also got
silly with the late-night host
playing a hilarious game of making
mundane things sound sexy with his
amazing voice my beige turtleneck is
peeling so please wash it
[Music]
[Applause]
No
over on watch what happens live Lea
Michele opened up about her former Glee
co-star Heather Morris's shocking
elimination on Monday's Dancing with the
Stars first of all that was ridiculous
because the reality is that Heather
already won Dancing with the Stars and
we were all really you know sad but I
think she's incredible the 30 year old
actress also revealed which of her Glee
performances she considered the worst
and best that what does the Fox say song
it was like an internet sensation song
that we did with like puppets
okay that was definitely my least
favorite song he ever did and then I
think the best was probably like
somebody to love or don't not believe in
[Music]
you